[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا قال الجنرال مارتن
ديمسي رئيس اركان الجيش الامريكي ان تنظيم
الدوله كاد يصل الى مطار بغداد الدولي
لولا تدخل طائرات الاباتشي الامريكيه
واضاف ديمسي ان الدوره الامريكيه
الميدانيه في العراق قد يتسع في المرحله
المقبله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين دور القوات الامريكيه في توفير
الحمايه للعاصمه العراقيه في مواجهه تنظيم
الدوله وما هو مدى قدره القوات العراقيه
على حمايه
[موسيقى]
بغداد قال رئيس اركان الجيش الامريكي
الجنرال مارتن ديمسي ان مسلحي تنظيم
الدوله كانوا على بعد
25 ك من مطار بغداد الامر الذي استدع
التصدي لهم بمروحيات الاباتشي الامريكيه
لابعادهم عن المطار وقال المسؤول الامريكي
ان واشنطن قد تقوم بدور اكبر في تقديم
المشوره والمساعده للقوات العراقيه على
الارض في المستقبل تطورات جاءت بينما
يلتقي في واشنطن رؤساء اركان 21 من دول
التح العسكري ضد تنظيم الدوله لبحث
استراتيجيه مواجهه
التنظيم هل باتت العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
حقا في مرمى نيران تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
سؤال املته تطورات الميدانيه الاخيره في
العراق حيث استولى مقاتلو التنظيم على
مدينه هيت غير البعيده عن بغداد بعد
انسحاب الجيش العراقي منها لكن المؤشر
الاقوى على ما يتهدد العاصمه العراقيه هو
ما اعلنه رئيس اركان الجيش الامريكي
الجنرال مارتن ديمبسي من ان مطار بغداد
الدولي كاد يسقط بايدي تنظيم الدوله لولا
تدخل طائرات الاباتشي الامريكيه ووفق
ديمبسي فان مقاتلي التنظيم كانوا على بعد
25 كيلومترا فقط عن المطار وان التدخل كان
على عجل وخطرا في ان لجهه الارتفاع
المحدود لتحليق الاباتشي
السلطات العراقيه سارعت الى نفي تصريحات
ديمسي والتاكيد على ان المطار امن لكن
اخبارا عن توتر واجراءات استثنائيه في
بغداد والمنطقه الخضراء عادت وتواترت
الثلاثاء مع نفي جديد من
السلطات مطار بغداد الدولي هو اكبر مطارات
العراق يقع على بعد 16 كيلومترا غربي
المدينه وهو بالغ الحيويه والرمزيه فقد
كان سقوطه عام 2003 مؤذنا بسقوط بغداد
واحتلال العراق يرى خبراء ان حزام بغداد
ومن مناطق ابو غريب والتاج والطار ميه
والمشاهده والمدائن سيكون حاسما في اي
اختراق محتمل للمدينه فتلك المناطق تعد
خاصره رخوه بالنظر خاصه الى ما يكنه
سكانها من كره للقوات العراقيه
والميليشيات
رافقه لها جراء تجاوزاتها وانتهاكاتها
ضدهم ناهيك عن ان الانسحاب تلو الانسحاب
للجيش العراقي من مدن عده اولها الموصل
واخرها هيت لا يبعث على الوثوق لا امريكيا
ولا عراقيا بقدرته على الصمود في حزام
بغداد وبالتالي في حمايه
العاصمه لا يخفي تنظيم الدوله مسعاه للظفر
ببغداد وقد روج مبكرا لمحاولاته تل منذ
حزيران يونيو الماضي ساعتها كثر الحديث عن
اقتراب ساعه الصفر وعن خلايا نائمه
للتنظيم في العاصمه فهل يفعلها في الخريف
بعدما اتضح ان محاوله الصيف كانت اقرب الى
حرب النفسيه استفادت من ارتباك المشهد
السياسي واصرار نور البالك حينها على
التمسك بمنصب رئيس
الوزراء موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
واشنطن لاري كورب كبير الباحثين في مركز
التقدم الامريكي ومساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي السابق وكذلك من عمان الكاتب
والبحث السياسي العراقي وليد الزبيدي وقد
ينضم الينا من لندن عبر سكايب الدكتور
موفق الربيعي عضو لجنه الامن والدفاع في
مجلس النواب العراقي ابدا معك سيد زبيدي
هل تعتقد بان سيناريو الموصل واغلبيه
مناطق الانبا يمكن ان يصل فعلا الى
بغداد هذا الهدف المعلن كما قال ابو محمد
العدناني في
كلمته التي تزامنت مع احداث الموصل في
حزيران الماضي وقال ان بغداد هي الهدف
ايضا هناك اكثر من اشاره الى ان المعركه
الرئيسيه وال الحاسمه في بغداد
ستكون ولكن يعني في قراءه تطور الاحداث
وما قاله دمسي وما يصرح به المسؤولون في
بغداد العسكريون والسياسيون واضح انهم
دخلوا من حيث يعلمون او لا يعلمون تحت
تاثير الصدمه والترويع يعني انا استطيع ان
يعني اصف احوالهم النفسيه الامريكيين
والعراقيين
بالضبط يعني اوضاع الحكومه العراقيه قبل
بدايه الحرب في 2003 فكان للصدمه والترويع
امر مهم جدا وبالمناسبه ايضا كما جاء في
في التقرير عندما دخلت القوات الامريكيه
في
34/23 الى مطار بغداد بدات يعني معالم
كثير من الانهيار وعندما خرجت قوات دبابات
امريكيه في مطار بغداد من مركز المطار الى
ساحه ام الطبول يوم
54 في حركه استعراضيه وبثت تلك الصور قناه
فوكس الامريكيه تسبب ذلك بانهيار فعل كبير
بمعنى ان المطار يعني مكان س ورمزي مهم
وايضا الطريق الرئيسي الذي يمتد من المطار
الى المنطقه الخضراء يمكن قطع مسافه قصيره
في حال وجود انهيار في الاجهزه الامنيه
وهذا ما يتوقعه الكثير من المراقبين سيد
لالي لاري كورب بالاستناد الى تصريح دمسي
هل يمكن ان نفهم ان بغداد خط احمر كما هي
اربيل بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده
ليس هناك ادنى شك بان بغداد تمثل اهميه
اكبر من اربيل بالنسبه لامريكا وكذلك
الموصل والولايات المتحده مستعده لتبذل
قصار
جهدها وبمساعده الدول التي تقدم قوات
وكذلك قوه قوات الحلفاء العسكريه
الجويه وكذلك هذه القوه التي تسمح لامريكا
ان تتدخل وتمنع تنظيم الدوله من الوصول
الى المطار كذلك اعتقد ان الجيش والقوه
العراقيه على ود تحديد الجانب الشيعي
سيقاتل بضراوه للدفاع عن المطار في حين ان
السنه لم يدافعوا عن الموصل على الاطلاق ا
دكتور موفق الرباعي انضم الينا من لندن
عبر سكايب دكتور هل بغداد برايكم اصبحت في
قطر خصوصا بعدما اي
كان على وشك ان يصبح المطار تحت مرمى
نيران تنظيم
الدوله بسم الله الرحمن بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اولا اريد ان ان اقول ان التشبيه
بين ما حدث لدى الجيش الامريكي في دخوله
في بغداد في 2003 و والان هو تشبيه جدا
بسيط وحقيقه ساذج
عسكريا بغداد يسكنها اكثر من بين 8 الى 9
مليون عراقي من من من هويات مذهبيه وعرق
معينه ولا يمكن لداعش ان تهدد عصابات داعش
ان تهدد بغداد باي شكل من اشكال الروايه
الامريكيه التي قالت انه كان المطار تحت
التهديد حقيقه
روايه يعني للاستهلاك المحلي في داخل
الولايات المتحده طبعا الولايات المتحده
بالضربات الجويه بدخول
الاباتشي بمساعدات
العسكريه والامنيه
والتخطيطيه مشكوره عليها انه ساعدت قواتنا
ولكن اطمئن اطمئن كل ابناء الامه العربيه
والاسلاميه ان بغداد في مامن وبغداد ليس
في يعني في خطر
وابناء البغداد سوف يعني يدافعون عن بغداد
هذه عاصمه يعني انت تنفي انت تنفي ما ورد
على لسان دمسي من ان المطار كان في خطر
وانه لولا تدخل طائرات الاباتشي لكانت
الامور في مكان اخر
اليوم لا اريد ان ادخل في جدال مع صديقي
مارتي دمسي وهو مشكور على جهوده في دعم
القوات العراقيه ولكن ما نريده من من
الولايات المتحده هو شيء واضح هو التسريع
ب بتجهيز بالف 16 والاباتشي واله فاير ع
دكتور موفق قلت ان هذا الخبر للاستهلاك
المحلي السؤال صحيح ام غير صحيح لانه على
اساسه سنست في
النقاش نحن لا نعتقد انه لمطار لا مطار
بغداد ولا مدينه بغداد مهدده من قبل
عصابات داعش نحن نعتقد انه قواتنا الامنيه
والشرطه والجيش والقوى وقوات مكافحه
الارهاب بامكانها وتمكنت ان تصد و تصد
عصابات داعش الى الخلف وطهرت المناطق اللي
هي في جنوب وجنوب غرب بغداد وطهرت مدينه
مدينه ابو غريب وكذلك هي في طريقها الى
تطهير شمال بغداد والتاجي والطار ميه وهذه
المناطق وجرفه الصخر والمناطق المحيطه في
بغداد فلا زالت القوات العراقيه لها اليد
طوله في في ساحه المعركه المعنويات عاليه
جدا اننا نحتاجه الى اعاده تدريب قواتنا
نحتاج نحتاج
الى يعني
هناك اذا استمعت الى سيد الربيعي هناك ثقه
بان بغداد لا يمكن ان تتعرض لخطر وبان
الجيش العراقي قادر على الصمود في بغداد
او في ضواحي بغداد ما
رايك واقعا بغداد في حاله رعب واسع
بالنسبه على المستويين الشعبي والحكومي
والامني الذي يتحدث ان بغداد امنه ويوميا
اختراقات امنيه هائله وخطيره واستهداف
للاجهزه الامنيه والمسؤولين اليوم قتل
وكيل وزير الداخليه السابق وعضو برلمان
وفي كل يوم انفجارات هائله انا لا اعرف
كيف تكون هذه الخروقات الهائله والخطيره
التي تستهدف الاجهزه الامنيه والحكوميه
وهناك من يتحدث ان بغداد امنه هذا جانب
موضوع بغداد حقيقه عندما يقول دمسي ان
الاباتشي هي التي منعت من الوصول
المقاتلين من الوصول الى بغداد هذا كلام
واقعي لانه المناطق المحيطه بالمطار
القريبه مننا كلها تشهد معارك وتنهزم
امامها القوات الحكوميه معروف القراغول
وفي ابو غريب وفي ايضا جنوب الفلوجه وغير
ذلك ما يؤكد الكلام لدم سي بان الاباتي هي
التي حمت علينا ان نعرف معلومتين مهمتين
الاولى ان مسلحي التنظيم واضح انهم تمكنوا
من استخدام مقاومه الطائرات التي استولوا
عليها من مطار الطبقه في الرقه في اسقاط
المروحيات كما حصل في اسقاط المروحيه
الروسيه مل 28 في بيجي ومروحيات اخرى في
صلاح الدين ايضا الخبر الاخر الذي يؤكد ان
سلاح الاباتشي وايضا مقاتلات حتى التحالف
قد تكون في خطر كبير ما ت اكد من استيلاء
مقاتلي التنظيم على شحنه اسلحه كبيره هذا
ما ذكرته مصادر امريكيه من بينها 380
صاروخ ستنجر هذا بمعنى ان هذه الصواريخ
هذه الاسلحه مع عدد هائل في حال ان تم
الانتهاء من الانبار اكثر من 200000 مقاتل
اصبح فيها حسب التقديرات يضاف الى 65000
في الموصل اعتقد بانه سنكون امام يعني
سيناريو الاول يكون هو الانتهاء من صلاح
الدين وسيكون ذلك بامر بسيط بهذا العدد
الكبير من المقاتلين والاسلحه وربما تطويق
بغداد او سيكون تطويق بغداد ومن ثم زلزال
داخل بغداد لا نعرف كيف يتم التخطيط له
ولكن واضح ان هذا الهدف سيد كول اذا تحقق
اذا تحقق ما ذكره السيد الزبيدي ماذا
سيكون عليه دور القوات الامريكيه الولايات
المتحده عموما هل ستكتفي بطائرات اباتشي
بقصف من الجو كما تفعل حاليا او او ربما
يتوسع هذا الدور الى ما هو اكبر نحو قوات
بريه من
جديد
و في واقع الامر اعتقد انه من المهم ان
ناخذ في الحسبان ان تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ليست لديه القدرات العسكريه
المتاحه لامريكا عندما اجتاحت بغداد في
السابق اعتقد ان تلك المقاربه
تلك المقاربه ساذجه عندما كان دمسي يتحدث
عن استخدام مروحيات لا باتشي ما قاله ان
هذه
المروحيات مسلحه بشكل افضل للضرب واستهداف
اهداف متحركه على الارض بينما الطائرات
والمقاتلات الموجوده في ابعد في السماء
يصعب عليها ذلك اذا هناك ايضا فرق بين
السيطره على المطار والسيطره على البغداد
واعتقد ققد انه من الناحيه النفسيه سيكون
مهم بالنسبه لتنظيم الدوله ان تسيطر على
المطار وانا سعيد ان امريكا وقفتهم لكن ما
يهم في نهايه المطاف ان الامر منوط
بالعراقيين ان يقاتلوا ويدافعوا عن بلدهم
امريكا يمكن ان تساعد لكننا لن نبعث
بالكثير من الوحدات القتاليه مجددا الرئيس
اوضح ذلك بشكل واضح والشعب الامريكي لا
يدعم ذلك لكن الحكومه الشموليه والجديده
في العراق يعتقد انها يجب ان تحظى
بالتشكيله البشريه الكافيه للدفاع عن
البلد بما فيها داخل جيد كافه الموجودين
من الامريكيين يعملون مع القوات العراقيه
لتضمن انهم مدربين وان لديهم الاستراتيجيه
للتعامل مع تنظيم الدوله ابقى معنا سيد
كرب وسيد الزبيدي وسيد ربيعي فاصل
مشاهدينا نواصل بعده نقاش موضوعنا ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش مدى جاهزيه واستعداد القوات
العراقيه والامريكيه للتصدي لاي هجوم
محتمل من تنظيم الدوله على بغداد اعود الى
ضيفي من لندن موفق الربيعي دكتور موفق
اشرت قبل قليل الى ان المطلوب هو تسليح
الجيش العراقي تسريع التسليح التدريب
واعاده البناء لكن انت تعرف ان هذه امور
تحتاج الى وقت طويل بينما الخطر داهم بين
ليله
وضحاها بمن يمكن ان يستعين العراقيون
الجيش العراقي فيما لو كان هناك هجوم فعلا
على بغداد بمن يمكن ان يستعين من قوات
خارجيه
ربما لا نحتاج الى اي تدخل بقوات على
الارض خارجيه سو انه دوليه او اقليميه ما
نحتاجه الان لدينا مليون ونص عراقي تحت
السلاح يتدربون ويقاتلون بنفس الوقت ل
دعنا نقارن ما بين الان وما بين 2007 2006
كانت بغداد نصف بغداد الكرخ تحت سيطره
القاعده
والرصافة الامنيه سواء انه السيارات
المفخخ او اذا احتجتم عفوا اذا احتجتم
يعني انت تتحدث انت تتحدث بثقه كبيره
السؤال اذا كان هناك فعلا خطر هل يمكن ان
تستدع اي قوات اجنبيه نعم ام لا لكل حادث
حديث ولا واستبعد انه نحتاج الى اي قوات
اجنبيه ولا يمكن ان نعيد الاحتلال من حيث
بدا نحن يعني جاهدنا وظنا وكافح من اجل
انهاء الاحتلال واسترجاع السياده العراقيه
والاستقلال العراقي والوحده العراقيه سيد
كورب
يعني مسؤولون ايرانيون تحدثوا اكثر من مره
مره عن الاستعداد للدفاع عن
الاماكن الدينيه في بغداد وايضا بعض
المسؤولين تحدثوا عن انه لولا ايران ل
سقطت بغداد هل يمكن ان تقبل للولايات
المتحده بدور عسكري ايراني تحت عنوان
حمايه بغداد في
العراق من الناحيه الرسميه الامر غير وارد
لكن من الناحيه غير الرسميه فهو وارد لو
تذكرتم خطاب الوزير الخارجيه كريي في الام
المتحده عندما تحدث عن العراق فقد تحدث عن
مساعده الايران
الايرانيون في السابق عملوا مع القوات
العراقيه في حدود الموصل وسدها وقاموا
بتدريب الميليشيات الشيعيه اذا اعتقد ان
ايران لن تسمح بسقوط بغداد وانما ستقوم
بما عليها من ناحيه العسكريه ان تمنع حدوث
ذلك يعني قلت انه بطريقه رسميه لا لكن
يعني هل يمكن ان نفهم ان هناك نوع من
اتفاق تحت الطاوله بين الولا
المتحده وايران بالنسبه لبغداد تحديدا او
للتدخل البري في
العراق ليس هناك ادنى شك من ان الطرفين ي
يعملان مع بعضهما البعض فالا الانيون
قدموا المساعدات العسكريه للبش مر من خلال
معدات عسكريه قدمها لهم في منطقه كردستان
وبالتالي هذا الامر موجود وكما قلت في
الوزير كري في خطابه امام الا المتحده حدث
تحدث عن هذا الامر لذلك ان الايرانيين في
العراق والتحالف الذي تقده امريكا لديهم
اهداف مشتركه تتمثل في منع تنظيم الدوله
من السيطره على اراضي اضافيه وارتكاب فضاع
مرعه ضد الشعب
العراقي سيد الزبيدي ما رايك
بامكانيه هذا التدخل كان امريكيا او حتى
ايرانيا فيما لو حصل ان تعرضت بغداد لهجوم
او
خطر التدخل موجود سيدي الكريم الايرانيون
قالوا بشكل رسمي بان يعني هم الذين حاموا
بغداد من السقوط علما بان معركه بغداد لم
يتم الاعلان عنها ولم تبدا رغم ذلك قالوا
نحن حمينا اربيل ونحن حمينا بغداد هذا امر
رسمي والسيد قاسم سليماني كان في في منطقه
مدينه امرلي العراقيه ظهر هناك وهو
ومجاميع كبيره منه ولكن الامر بالاخير لا
يعتمد على تدخلات للايراني الايرانيين
بالمناسبه معروفين بانهم يدفعون غيرهم
يقاتلون بالنيابه عنهم ليس في العراق وحده
ولكن الامر يعتمد على الجيش والاجهزه
الامنيه والجيش والاجهزه الامنيه في
العراق منهاره وهناك مؤشرين انا يعني احب
اذكرهم المؤشر الاول يعرف جميع البغداديين
عندما تحصل انفج ارات بين 10 الى 20
انفجار في احد الايام حصل 21 انفجار يعرف
البغداديون انه لم يبقى شخص في الشارع من
الاجز الامنيه وهذا دليل على ان الهزيمه
في داخلهم ولا يمكن ان يعود شيء يبني هذه
الهزيمه الامر المؤشر الثاني السيد
المالكي قبل حزيران الماضي باربعه او خمسه
اشهر قال عدونا الاساسي في الموصل ونعم
حشد اكبر قوه امنيه من النخبه وغير ذلك في
الموصل عدد الشرطه الاتحاديه الجيش
والصحوات معهم وغير ذلك وصل ل 200,000 هذه
النخب والقوه الهائله من الاسلحه
والمقاتلين من الجيش وغيرها 200,000
تبخروا خلال اربع ساعات فقط امام مقاتلي
المسلحين ومقاتلي الدوله الاسلاميه عليه
في حال معركه بغداد اعتقد لا القوه الجويه
الامريكيه تستطيع ان تعمل والاباتشي قد
تستهدف هي والمروحيات بالاسلحه التي
ذكرتها ضد المروحيات والباكي ولا القوى
الايرانيه ستتمكن من حمايه بغداد بل ستكون
اعتقد س
الرب يعني استمعت الى كل هذا التوصيف ل
الواقع هناك نقطه مهمه هل بغداد في
اجواء التنسيق غير المعلن كما ذكر سيد
جورب بين ايران والولايات المتحده فيما
يتعلق بامكانيه حمايه بغداد لو تعرضت
للهجوم او خطر
السقوط قبل الاجابه على سؤالك دعني اقول
نقطتين اساسيتين النقطه الاولى ان نحن لا
نرى ان هناك تناقض بين علاقه العراق
الحميميه والصمم مع مع ايران وبين العلاقه
الاستراتيجيه مع الولايات المتحده بين
العراق والولايات المتحده نرى احدهما يكمل
الاخر ولا ولا نرى تناقضا بينهما النقطه
الثانيه الايرانيون كانوا في بغداد في
اليوم الثاني عند ما تهددت بغداد في
حزيران من هذه السنه في اليوم الثاني يوم
ع يوم 11 هم موجودين في حزيران من هذا
العام وكانوا يدعمون القوات العراقيه
بالتخطيط
والتنسيق القضايا
الاستخباريه اجبني اجبني على هذا سؤال
فيما يتعلق فيما يتعلق بالدور الايراني في
بغداد لو ترجم ميدانيا باختصار سيد
الربيعي لا يمكن ل وكما هو كما اعلن
الايرانيون ذلك انفسهم انه لا يمكن ممكن
ان يسمحوا للعتبات المقدسه التي في بغداد
وفي سمراء وفي كربلاء والنجف ان تكون تحت
سيطره عصابات عصابات داعش فلذلك نحن لدينا
عمق استراتيجي مع الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
وحليف استراتيجي هو الولايات المتحده
فهؤلاء
كلا هذه قوه ايران هي قوه عظمى بالمنطقه
بالاقليم واللا المتحده سيد كور سيد كور
باختصار
باختصار الولايات المتحده البيت الابيض
تحديدا يؤكد عدم فعاليه كبيره ل الضربات
الجويه في اجتماع رؤساء الاركان اليوم في
واشنطن هل يمكن ان تعدل الاستراتيجيه
باتجاه تحريك قوات او ايجاد قوات دوليه
معينه او شيء من هذا القبيل على الارض
طبعا نع
لن تكون هناك قوات امريكيه وقوات تابعه
للناتو في العراق في العراق سيكون الامر
منوطا بالقوات العراقيه هي التي ستكون على
الارض وفي سوريا ستكون المقاومه
والمقاتلين السوريين المعتدلين وكذلك
الجيش السوري الحر سيد لاري كورب من
واشنطن اشكرك جزيلا واشكر الكاتب وليد
الزبيدي من عمان وشكرا للدكتور موفق
الربيعي من لندن
بهذا تنتهي حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر شكرا للمتابعه والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء